vice president harris touching down in
guatemala yesterday kicking off a trip
through central america to address what
her office is calling the root causes
of the crisis down at the southern
border but critics say she's not going
far enough urging her to witness the
crisis
at the border firsthand fox nation host
laura logan
just spent a week covering this crisis
and she joins us now good morning to you
laura
good morning good morning where did you
go down on the border and what did you
see
well i was down in the rio grande valley
area which is
in texas and we went all over because i
was with
the texas department of public safety
and so some of the time was in the air
a lot of the time on the ground and we
were out day and night so all through
the valley out to
roma which is one of the biggest
smuggling corridors that's the video
that you're looking at
right there was filmed in roma late at
night and
that was just quite extraordinary to see
that even the smuggler
was not concerned about um agents from
texas department of public safety and
border patrol agents
being right there on the riverbank it's
just so common now
and everybody knows the game you know
come over hand yourself
over if you have a shot of getting in
the country and otherwise
you know hit one of the other areas and
just run run for your life
because no one's going to enforce the
law for minor enforce you know
immigration violations
so um the only real uh problem here is
criminal activity
and there's so many places the border is
so wide open in all the areas where
there is no border wall and there's very
little coverage
that it was just quite it was almost
shocking to see
um that there really is an open border
and this administration is not talking
about it or even acknowledging it
was that the biggest change you saw the
number of people coming through
or was it the fact that these smugglers
are just letting you
film them and they're not getting
arrested they're not getting
nothing's happening to them
you know the biggest change that i saw
was hearing from agents all along the
border
from every different kind of agency that
they've never seen anything
in their lifetimes like they're seeing
now because the numbers are
up on every single part of the border
and perhaps
um and that's never happened before
there's always you know there have been
a number
of crises that have come and gone but in
all of those situations the
administration in washington
has acknowledged that there's a crisis
and has
taken action to mitigate what is
happening
that is not happening here in fact the
only action that has been taken
has been to create the crisis so it's
not that there's a lack of policy
it's that the policy is to open the
border
and it's not that there's a failure of
action the action has been
to open the border and obliterate um
immigration law
and to prevent law enforcement from
enforcing it so
texas has stepped in the breach here so
as arizona and new mexico
but there's just millions and millions
and millions of dollars
that are being spent the biden
administration is spending it
on immigrants and that has left national
security
and security up to the states
so texas is filling that gap and that's
what really you know
texas has filled in temporarily before
but there's always been some kind of
acknowledgement from washington
that you are in the midst of a crisis
and what kamila harris
has not done as so-called borders are
she hasn't spoken to the people who are
living on the border in
any of these states she hasn't been down
and visited any of these communities
she hasn't acknowledged any of these
problems she hasn't spoken to the
ranchers who
literally have gotten uh you know
they're just like a
highway of illegal immigrants who are
trying to avoid the law
i mean we we're talking about areas you
know where there's
never been people coming through i mean
that have got three
400 increase in the number of people
that are coming over
and uh and so that's a shock and this is
being felt in the communities because
you have car chases
and you have uh bailouts where people
know that they're caught and so they
just
you know bailouts in the middle of the
of the street and people um
you know this is putting people at risk
there's a rising crime even where i
am you know i'm i'm far from north of
the border and
there's been a massive increase in crime
in small towns
in the countryside so this is a real
issue that is not being addressed by
this administration and that has never
been the case
in living memory what i've spoken almost
a 1400
increase in sexual offenders in the re
in the del rio sector
griff jenkins was telling us earlier and
he interviewed one rancher who said he
feels completely abandoned by this
administration they are down there
in the triangle countries but they're
not dealing with americans on that side
of the border
laura thanks for going down there for us
and and reporting the story
we appreciate it also ainsley there's
people coming from 120 countries
120 countries kamala harris is she going
to address immigration problems and root
causes in all of those countries
the whole world is coming to america
right now and coming over the border and
disappearing we don't even know who they
are
and this administration has done um
everything they've put this in place
deliberately laura thank you so much
laura logan
i'm steve ducey i'm brian killman and
i'm ainsley earhart and click here to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
to catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis